to bring you an update from the  Department of Health and Social Care on  their official Twitter account they have  just posted the following information  informing us that the number of  confirmed covert 19 cases in the UK has  gone up from 53 to 85 I'll just read you  there Toit professor Chris witty the  chief medical officer officer saying as  of 9 a.m. this morning 32 in England  have tested positive for covert 19:29  had recently traveled from recognized  countries or from recognized clusters  which were under investigation three  additional patients contracted the virus  in the UK and it is not yet clear  whether they contracted it directly or  indirectly from an individual who had  recently returned from abroad this is  being investigated and contact tracing  has begun  you